[Music]
there are so many people in life they
forget to dream because they're afraid
of going out of their comfort zone
thirteen years ago two enterprising
pilots shared a dream to achieve the
impossible
their goal to build the first
solar-powered plane to fly around the
world ushering in an aviation future
free of fossil fuels and pollution
our goal is simply demonstrate that it's
feasible
tango x-ray their plan was ambitious
to cross the globe in 17 legs over the
course of a year
logging 25 000 miles
taking turns in the cockpit co-pilots
bertrand picard and andre borschberg
knew that they would face technical and
operational challenges we have to go
back while battling weather and the
elements it has been really a difficult
moment in an unprecedented bid for
adventure and glory
[Music]
when i was a child
all the people i knew were explorers
adventurers and astronauts you know when
i was a boy i read a lot of books about
the pilots who opened the lines
basically discovered the worlds through
airplanes he's determined to succeed
this time he has spent my grandfather
was the first man in the stratosphere
inventing the pressurized capsule
and then my father made the deepest dive
ever touching the bottom of the marina
trench the deepest spot on earth
and showing that the deepest trenches in
the oceans had to be protected
but that was fascinating by the people
who tried something new something
different
i thought exploration was the only way
to live
i flew non-stop around the world in a
balloon we burned almost four tons of
propane gas it was pollution and i was
thinking how can i do it with no fuel
and this is how the dream of solar
impulse started flying a solar powder
plane
that produces its own electricity with
the sun
store the electricity in batteries
so you can fly through the night fly to
the next sunrise forever then when i met
bertrand 13 years ago i immediately had
the impression that my life was crossing
something extremely important i found
that andrei
was the missing part of me
and i was the missing part of him he's
the engineer entrepreneur jet fighter
pilot
i'm a medical doctor i'm an explorer so
i asked him if he would agree to partner
with me to do it
and he accepted immediately together
we could be the complete human being
[Music]
it's a very difficult airplane to fly
maybe the most difficult airplane in the
world to fly because of its huge
wingspan very lightweight and
sensitivity to turbulence so this you
have to master completely so at the
beginning you just over control it it's
a disaster
using the simulator allowed us we to
yeah get the feeling about the
personality of this airplane to know how
to handle it and i had the clearance
from the tower
and i could put full throttle
no noise
from the engines and the plane taking
off
and i'm just looking to stay in the air
as long as i can no limit
[Music]
when we travel
it takes three days
to fly where other people would fly with
a jet plane in eight hours
[Music]
but you know that you can stay there
forever
and what is magical
is to look at the sun
to look at the
propellers on both sides
to see them turning without noise and
without pollution
and to think
i'm in the film of science fiction
it cannot be true
but it is true
[Music]
so as soon as aldrey can put
full power on the four electrical
engines
around the world will start
and i repeat
always it's an attempt
around the world with solar impulse 2
started in march 2015
andre and i we took turns in the cockpit
[Music]
prince albert is next to me and he will
give the official go and then the
adventure will start my friend it's a
great pleasure to wish you all all the
best for this fantastic
crossing of of the pacific so you are
clear to proceed with the takeoff
procedures
as soon as as i took off from japan one
important equipment failed
and immediately the engineers told me
that i had to return to japan to fix it
but i looked at it completely
differently that was the first time that
the weather was improving of the pacific
[Music]
i would say we have to go back as we
have the choice the engineers never
understood that they never understood
why i was taking this risk some of them
wanted to resign immediately and i
decided to continue
[Music]
only so much we can do to support you
from here from the ground you will be on
your own let's go for it and thank you
for helping me thank you for helping us
i strongly believe it's not a perfect
gamble it has been really a difficult
moment do we go we don't go but the
weather is good the plane flies well
it's worth trying
i did meditation i couldn't sleep
and slowly at sunrise i could throw this
emotion overboard
and i could go back to what i've been
dreaming about to enjoy these days i was
over the pacific ocean i don't know how
many records we were setting in this
flight and it's the most difficult
flight of the whole journey around the
world that we succeeded
[Music]
[Applause]
exploration is not
only when you are successful and you
raise the flag of victory
it's through all these moments where you
have the impression to lose control the
throwing plus two missions started in
abu dhabi with many stop-overs across
asia first over the pacific
across the united states
of the atlantic across the mediterranean
sea
and to get back here in the middle east
i crossed the finish line
over abu dhabi and i had one hour and a
half in the air waiting before landing i
could be in the full
emotion of the success
but still in the full emotion of the
adventure
and at that moment i thought
everything is possible
[Music]
everything is possible
why don't we dream more why don't we try
more
and a few hours ago i had to open the
door of the cockpit i had to land
and this flight around the world became
memories
[Applause]
what we did here
was 3d pioneering work and that's the
industry slowly is understanding the
potential of these technologies in 10
years you will use electric airplanes
maybe not solar
this will take more time but certainly
electric
if you have an impossible goal the
people who are going to support you
are pioneers
[Music]
you